kind of everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Sienna spalling this
from Sienna Spaulding TV introduce
yourself hey guys I'm Sienna Spaulding
from CSI TV that's what I said and she's
gonna teach me how to dance on this year
pole been weird like that so what are we
doing first alright so first I really
teach you something that is very
ambitious move it's called the flagpole
okay so you're gonna stand on this side
of the pole wrap your elbow around so
you're going to be in your armpit okay
grab the pole here with a bent arm Roger
your other one's gonna go down and
you're gonna lift your body up returning
your chest to the camera and really seal
it Cindy Oh does it
who does it really let's try okay so get
my elbow in here yeah down here yeah my
body pretty amazing right arm high left
arm across your body left leg is going
to go on the pole eating nook of your
ankle okay you're gonna stick your booty
out and then fall to the left pick up
the back leg to the back side of the pub
okay
back leg to the back side yes so we're
sandwiching the pole with your feet like
that's like a cut so so the ain't going
front and then the this part of your
foot is going to go to the back side and
then I spin stick the booty out first
that booty oh yeah
oh yeah there we go um that was pretty
amazing thank you the literally like the
best firings that I've heard through my
life pretty good next so your foot is
gonna go here on the pole you're gonna
flex it you're gonna push your knee in
towards the pole uh-huh and the pressure
is gonna go on this foot arms up you're
gonna pull up back leg comes to the
front okay and then you can release okay
all right wait so what's wrong what's
wrong oh my god you break your foot up
no because I can do this someone else
television here okay okay
like that it's like it's gonna come to
the front you want to stand up on this
leg oh my god all right what's next
everyone pull up pull up cross one leg
over the other uh-huh then when you here
you can release an arm however because
you have yeah yeah I don't yeah yeah I
know you have to be more back here more
towards your knees okay all right okay I
got it okay
I'm getting too ambitious here right
right you see my skills are so I got up
you gotta jump up lift your body yeah
cross one leg over the other one like oh
yeah we're gonna get difficult now that
wasn't difficult before so shoulder go
against the pole you want to tilt your
head to one side so if anyone's like
arms up in a bent position okay now
watch out so I kick you just like you
just did with their arms down here but
now they're up here you're gonna tuck
into the ball and open up and then you
can release it yeah I don't think that's
gonna happen
all right what the hell was it mister
that like this okay use those ABS yes
your core pull those legs up okay it
hurts your shoulder bad suggesting okay
okay I'm torturing him I feel really bad
it's okay are you taking anything for
abused you're gonna use just your arms
for this I think this one you can do it
you're gonna pull up then I'm gonna drop
down I think you can try so if you don't
have a split that's perfectly fine as
you drop down then both of your legs or
an elf's our guy like a double stack
okay
so this sorry boss it's my life story
through next time truck all the way to
the floor of bend your legs what I'm
doing it again I mean do you wanna do
right oh are we trying to learn here
okay sure about that
yeah okay so I gotta bend my leg just a
girlfriend yeah and so your end up
stealing in a double standing on the
floor with your city okay okay that's
great I think I'm done I'm really
impressed with you I think a lot of
people out there or not but that doesn't
matter so thank you so much
Janice balding TV I am all done here so
thank you all so much for watching
hey you want to see more videos like
this you can go [ __ ] yourself I'm done
so thank you all so much for watching
I'll see you in the next video bye
Oh